one of the things that we've both been
converging on was something that i put
into my newsletter this week and i want
to talk about that so i'm going to read
the newsletter out for people that
didn't read it if you haven't read it go
to chriswilex.com books and you can sign
up for free
uh so one of the most common tensions i
talk about at the moment is between a
desire for success and a desire to feel
like we're enough success is a strange
thing presumably we want success because
we think a more successful life will
bring us more happiness meaning and
fulfillment here's the problem we
sacrifice the thing we want happiness
for the thing which is supposed to get
it success
failure can make you miserable but i'm
not sure success will make you happy one
of the most common dynamics i see
amongst high performers is this parents
want their child to do well parents
encourage their child to do well by
praising them when they succeed and
criticizing when they fail the child
learns that praise and admiration is
contingent on succeeding that lesson
metastasizes through early adulthood
into i am only worthy of love and
acceptance and belonging if i succeed
now powered by an internal feeling of
insufficiency this person is driven to
achieve many things they're prepared to
outwork out hustle and out suffer
everyone else because they're not just
running toward a life they want they're
running away from a life that they fear
success and progress ameliorates the
feelings of insufficiency therefore
success and progress become prioritized
above everything else now don't get me
wrong many high achievers genuinely love
the work that they do and many are
driven by a well-balanced simple desire
to maximize their time on this planet
rather than trying to fill a void inside
of themselves but if i was to place a
bet i'd guess that the majority of high
performers are driven by fears of
insufficiency rather than a holistic
desire to be better i think people who
are high achievers on average are more
miserable than the average person so
what does it mean that the people we
most admire are the ones with the least
admirable internal states if the pursuit
of success is in an effort to make us
happy and in the pursuit of success we
make ourselves miserable
why not shortcut the entire process and
just be happy
is that even possible now external
accolades do count for a lot i don't
think that recanting all worldly
possessions and retreating to a cave in
the woods is an optimal strategy some
degree of external material success is
important to make us feel validated and
satiate our desire for status and
respect but
external success won't fill an internal
void
insufficiency insufficiency adaptation
is this if your drive to succeed comes
from a fear of insufficiency and you
continue to disprove those fears with
success in the real world and yet the
feelings of insufficiency persists what
makes you think that the answer to this
problem is more success there's no clean
answer here the world is messy and we're
hopelessly irrational you don't need to
let go of all success goals but spend
some time working out whether there's a
shorter route to the life you want by
removing obstacles rather than just
pressing harder on the accelerator
i love it it sounds like you're
on the pathless path now uh basically
what i've written about but
uh i think this is such a fascinating
topic because it sort of describes my
own journey i went from somebody that
was what i call trying to get ahead
you're aiming at a future potential
success and you're saying okay i'm
willing to sacrifice and then now to get
there the problem is you never arrive
right and the funny thing is i didn't
have the parents praising me or
criticizing me for achieving or not
achieving goals
i fully
brought this upon myself
in college i was just around people who
had those parents and i was like ooh
they want all these things i want what
they want right classic mimetic desire
and i did that for the next
12 13 years
until
i just slowly more reflection and more
reflection realized
holy crap this isn't me
i thought it was like 10 percent
different than those people around me
strategy consultants high achievers in
the corporate world i was probably one
or two standard deviations little
different in terms of what are the
elements of um
life that are gonna bring me alive
and connect me to who i am
what were the biggest differences
i think
i have an unreasonable need for autonomy
and freedom over my life the things i do
the ideas i work on and how i do it
most people are willing to sacrifice a
lot of those things
in exchange for like security and a
paycheck
right i was not pricing uh
that appropriately i didn't get as big a
benefit
and i was paying bigger costs for like
what i was giving up
um the problem and the reason i stayed
on my previous path so long was that i
didn't have an imagination of a
different possible life
my only model of the world was work hard
get ahead keep working for the future
indefinitely
there was no like alternative path
so i think deep deep down i was seeking
what you wrote about this past week of
basically just trying to be happier
and i didn't know
how to get there or
i didn't have models i had like role
models of like people i admired who
embodied that state people like seth
godin later in life creative fully alive
and engaged with the world i had no idea
how to get there though it's just his
existence was like that's possible that
seems worth trying to figure out what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
oh